Christian Elder, Screenwriter: You don't even know
this is this is like this got Netflix all over it
I’m telling you HBO max and Netflix
they're going to be battling it out over
“She Ain't Got Time For That.”
Film Courage: Big Bear mountain, a weightlifting
competition a stock broker six sisters
a plane crash three pennies gambling
addiction Friday at midnight
benefits of hard work a man on the run and lastly
this piece of dialogue she ain't got time for that
again you don't have to use all 11. okay
you know I've actually seen some
some movies about these things
all right
let's see
well a lot of these are really classic
and I mean I'm almost inclined to like
string many of them together into like like the
string some of them actually into like one um
but I don't think I'll do that
so like if I were to like take
something like like gambling addiction.
I don't really think that is a cause or
an effect so to speak so you'd have to
kind of develop a cause and effect around
it so so you'd have like something like a
a police officer
with
a gambling addiction
must
resolve
his debt
to a
notorious
gangster okay
by
murdering his partner
the officers partner or the gangster's partner no
he is the cops partner oh wow okay so what that
what that creates is a cause and effect it's not
the cause is resolving is dead it's not it's not
the gambling addiction the gambling addiction
is his I forget what it's there's actually a
name for it I want to say misbehavior but
I don't think that's the correct one but
it it does not it may predicate the
cause but it's not a part of the cause
the effect is that he has to he has to to
kill his partner which is kind of messed up
so yeah that's how that one would work a man on
the run there's so many men on the run movies
it's like things that always
happens it's like the big cliche
oh a man on the run after
run after
a bank heist
um
after a bank heist
and this is not the officer no
no this is different okay um
thank guys I'm stuck here after thank heist
i want to say but I don't think it's going to work
must reconcile this is dopey with his daughter
who ultimately
turns him in
okay it's getting interesting yeah
let's see let's take another one
three lucky pennies no or three pennies
retrieved from the bottom of the fountain
bottom of a fountain
bestow
three wishes
that reverse
into curses
let's see
a weightlifting
competition
turned
turns into
two
weightlifting competition there's something
there's another element that needs to be
in there because there's no real cause
established a weightlifting competition
a weightlifting competition
ah that's because it needs
a bodybuilder
entering
a weight lifting competition
competition
meets
his lifelong idol
and
and has conflicted
the long premise feelings
competing
against him after learning after learning
so the drama of course he's fighting cancer
what you want to do is you want to learn to
make that shorter for your kids out there
all right Friday at midnight a young what's he do
a young high school dropout
in
the 1950s
discovers
his
his his purpose
Fridays
at midnight
drag racing
at
the
vocal
street oh no dragging dry
racing on the off streets
of this small town
there you go now let's see
what else we got here let's tackle she ain't
got time for that because that one's just weird
that one's just odd
hey
a tv
comedian
is
by the role
she played
on screen
and
is becomes
violently
ill
every time
a fan
utters
her famous catchphrase
catchphrase actually I'm gonna write this one
she ain't got time for it
you don't even know this is this is
like this got Netflix all over it
I’m telling you HBO max and Netflix
they're going to be battling it out over
she ain't got time for that
no all right let's see what
else is here a stock broker
trading
and high finance
on wall street
starts
selling shares
man
let's just go for really
fantastical starts showing shares
in the afterlife
done
six sisters
spur-lunking
I’m sorry what does that mean oh
it's like it's cave diving oh okay
okay get trapped
in
and losing oxygen
must soon
come to the decision
of who lives or dies before someone rescues them
someone rescues rescues them
how many do you have left over eleven
one two three wow I did all them
great okay can you combine the remaining three
into one log line yeah I'll try yeah okay
actually this is pretty set up
for me right there to be honest um
this one it does have a cause
in Big Bear mountain
the survivors
of a plane crash it's pretty it's writing itself
must
save
the injured
through I'll just make it
simple through the benefits
of hard work
and cooperation
so which of which log line is your favorite
that you've created oh that's one easy
one it's a tv comedian is haunted by a tv comedian
is haunted by the role she played on screen and
becomes violently ill every time a fan utters her
famous catchphrase she ain't got time for that's
a winner and why do you why does that
resonate so much for you well it's not
so much that it resonates it's that's not at
all why it resonates the nature of a log line
is is is a couple of things and these many of
these if not all of these and I was having fun
um violate pretty much the strict rules of a
log line and and one of those is that is brevity
a long line should be concise
that one's not so concise
but it does the other thing a long line should
do it grabs your attention so then so technically
a log line is is something that if you're over
conversation over dinner you can say casually
to your dinner guest or to whoever it is or even
if you're just you're pitching it over dinner
and you can just let it roll off your tongue
and it have a sort of ring to it and a ring and
a verisimilitude then then usually or hopefully
someone responds to it like oh well that's
nice oh that's interesting I’d like to see that
it's it's it's the thing that sort of makes you
go I want to know more and that's really the
objective that's the purpose of a log line because
it I mean well okay I’m gonna back that up too
the log line also helps you design your screenplay
that is one that's that's another purpose you can
use it for but at the end of the day when
you're done with your screenplay and you've
you've refined your log
line and you make it concise
you need to be able to give it to the world and
use it as a hook so a lot of the log lines that
you came up with you said they were too long
especially the one that you really loved that
it's got to be shorter so if we were going to
take let's say the log line for Fargo I know you
said you liked the Coen brothers work yeah
or A Serious Man or something like what
what how would we shorten that down because that
would be hard a serious man that would be kind of
difficult to have a shorter long line with that
I don't know there I mean if you look up if you
you there's there there are smarter men than me
that have defined the log lines for for those
films and you can look them up you can google them
and they they're very brief actually I've read one
for a serious man and it is kind of brief if you
want to borrow the allegory from something else
to describe like movies like that it's usually
it's not you don't have to reach too far um
like um a what is a serious man's like a cancer
diagnosis leads to a journey of discovery for
a man that often considered himself invisible
and now comes to comes to a sense of rebirth
I mean that's the it it's pretty simple
and and what it is is like and if any
writer or writer who's a reader I would
say is like when they see a movie like
a serious man or they are familiar with the
script a serious man they'll go well this is just
the odyssey by homer it's pretty it's the same
thing and believe me the calm brothers knew it
was the odyssey by homer as they were writing
it's kind of a blatant who was psy in the odyssey
I don't know but I think maybe the I would say
he was the cyclops the the he they they they've
returned to the odyssey again and again the audi
they actually did an explicit interpretation of
the odyssey with oh brother whereof or brother
where though is the odyssey beat by beat
remember John Goodman at the tree with the
patch on his eye he is the cyclops so yeah
and so with this what would be the title for
this comedian who who's really just repulsed
by this famous role that she's known for and all
the fans want to repeat it to her what would you
call it oh I that well it's in the it's in the log
line it's the it's the catch phrase she ain't got
time for that okay and why why does that make
her ill why why does she not like that role
well it makes her violently ill like physically in
in in the way I would foresee it so like she would
have actual physical reaction she would convulse
she would she would she and and it would become
progressively worse and and manifest itself in
probably some very gruesome strange way and and
take it to its to it's inexorable extreme so I
have fun with it it's a it's a very humorous um
premise and I I enjoyed it I rarely
actually write things like that but I also
but I do find those kind of things entertaining
and what I end up doing is usually this is like
I take things like that and I make them quite
serious along the way that's why I like the Coen
brothers because they they're they're they're
they're satirists in a serious way quite often.